all right hello everyone how are you
guys doing hope you guys are having a
wonderful day and today I wanted to make
a video on something that I actually
thought was a little interesting I just
had a sudden urge I don't know I was I
was just watching videos and I was like
this is something that could probably be
helpful because I don't know what the
answer is to it and therefore I would
assume not a ton of people know so
recently if you guys don't know there
was an update to gargoyles and a lot of
other [__] Slayer TAS like neck reels
dust devils stuff like that to actually
make them profitable and worth doing
because I mean they really weren't dust
devils kind of work as you can and them
but other than that they really weren't
worth doing so in up or and updating
them gargoyles now you can make
approximately like 800 K to a mill an
hour and I just wanted to see what would
be the best thing to do if you have an
alt account or you just want to do some
easy afk money so the like since I
updated drop tables I guess last time
the ultimate way to go about doing this
and making money afk was always wyverns
because why friends have really good
drops and they're pretty afk as long as
you can find an empty spot so that's
what people have always done now you
have gargoyles and I'm just kind of
interested in which ones better so we're
gonna find out today I guess so I'm
probably gonna do either like half an
hour or an hour of both probably an hour
because why birds can be really fluky
because you could get like a couple
drops of seeds or battle staff drops and
then that might fluctuate the GP per
hour so this obviously isn't gonna be
perfect since it's only gonna be an hour
you could you could find that one maybe
like 50k more an hour but this is just
gonna be some rough estimation so let's
get on into it and let's see what we
could do alright so here we go you guys
might notice that we are not on the
normal account if you look down there I
guess give me a small [__] me alright
give me a second alright so as you can
see we're geared up ready to go I got
pretty much maxed out stuff I don't have
a beat ring I and other than that I also
do I'm a fire cape on this alt account I
didn't want to use my mane because I
kind of wanted to train some [__] on him
and yeah so like a true alt we're gonna
go and use a different account so there
we go I'm gonna break the ruins and
teleport here in a second let me get a
timer ready and then we'll be good to go
all right so we're going to start the
timer
now okay let's go we're gonna run there
and get on our way so basically the only
things I'm bringing just a super combat
potion for obvious reasons I probably
should have brought a two or three dose
just so I could have another inventory
slot but I'm stupid I feel like you
could make the I don't know trips a
little faster that way I also have an
energy potion you don't need a stamina
just a waste of coins just to ring the
teleport out in spec what so the only
thing I guess you could improve upon
here is not having a four-dose super
combat maybe a two or a three and pray
or maybe a fish or like flicking piety
but since this is more of an alt account
thing I won't be flicking piety for
either this task or gargoyles because I
don't think it's realistic alright did
have to hop for a cup I'm probably like
a minute I had to hop some worlds and
find out what was going on also I want
you guys just uh know this won't be the
max I guess that you can get I do have
99 of everything but my dragon fire fuel
also is not filled so that'll be I don't
know a little non efficient but we'll
get some pretty accurate ideas I got a
super combat up I'm stupid just got a
leak blue not gonna be doing that but
you know something worthy of note I
guess alright so this probably gonna be
the last kill of the trip as you can see
this took us about 20 minutes which
means we're probably gonna get about
three trips in in this hour so we're at
37 30 I'm gonna price check what we got
so far so here we go just gonna throw up
all of this and so at almost 1/3 of the
way mark we are at about two hundred and
twelve K so I'm gonna trade that on over
to this account that's why I stopped
just so I could do all of this real
quick and we'll go on the next trip
alright done with trip number two and as
you can see nothing really going on here
still no battle staff drops which kind
of blow so I mean that's something I
guess you could look forward to that I
really haven't gotten any of so just
mage logs are the only thing keeping us
alive right now
alright so got everything I have for the
tuber for the hour long I did this I'm
gonna go trade it all over to my other
account and then we will swiftly get
into killing some gargoyles you [__]
kidding me alright so this isn't really
a guide for gargoyles but there is one
thing I'm gonna recommend and I don't
know if it's
Sara Lee like efficient but it would
seem to me that it would be basically
Vera x-blade skirt gives you a ton more
defense and instead of wearing proselyte
legs the only negative is that you don't
have to plus prior but realistically I
think that the defense this gives you is
really worth it one thing that I also
have for this is a SGS if you don't have
an SGS you might be doing or you might
be spending a little more because you
might have to do prate melee and piety
personally I think with a barracks plate
skirt and an SGS I should be able just
to do pray piety so I'm gonna go do an
hour this [__] and then ya see how they
will see how they compare so let's go
alright so here we go starting off one
thing that I would also recommend is you
can use a bludgeon personally I don't
have a bludgeon with me right now so I
didn't end up using one I also don't
want to really get my strength up
anymore since I'm really close to ninety
nine and kind of one get these all near
the same time so I'm using a whip and a
defender you could probably get a little
bit more per hour with a bludgeon so if
you have that go ahead and use it but
yeah with that being said I'm gonna get
right on into it also one other thing
you could do if you want to have this be
a little more AF cable as an all and
make you know a little bit more money
with if you take out the Berserker ring
and use a ring of wealth it'll
automatically pick up all of the coin
drops you have cuz these drop a lot of
like 10k coin drops so you know it'll
pick up all those automatically I don't
I don't think you'll get more you won't
end up making more per hour but it's
something that if you're trying to make
this a little more AF capable you can go
ahead and do that alright so here we go
this is the last kill I'm gonna pick up
these coins real quick and oh [__] look
at that I got a rude - H nice way to end
it off alright so for most part I out I
think two or two room two ages probably
before these three and probably two room
plate legs before these three so
obviously as you can see I have a huge
cash tag right now huge amount of money
oh it could be higher but since I have
the inventory space I may as well not
allocate to save about seven to eight K
in total so we're gonna go compare it to
my other account and see which one I've
made the most money off of all right so
still throwing some stuff in just to say
on the wyverns I feel like I got really
unlucky not getting any battle staff
drops or anything of real note so as you
can see I was able to get 660 K pretty
much I
say I spent around sixty K or so in
supplies so I average in that hour about
600 K off of wyverns however you do have
to realize that I did not get any battle
staff drops I didn't like realistically
if I got one battle staff drop and
probably a couple other drops that were
of note I feel like I'm terribly unlucky
in that hour but I would say wyverns
obviously as you can see here I was able
to make 600 K I would say they're closer
to 7 800 K so with that being said I do
think now gargoyles are probably more
profitable I'm just gonna I'm just gonna
look at myself instead of looking at a
trade screen but you guys have the idea
as to what I was getting at I think that
gargoyles now are more profitable um the
one problem is and I kind of wrote down
some things I wanted to go over with
wyverns they are more afk and you do
have a chance at a busy so if you guys
want to take that chance or if you're on
an Ironman and need to take that chance
or whatever that's probably a better
option if you if you would like to risk
it a little more it's a one and I think
10k drop so it's it's highly unlikely
and would barely affect the GP per hour
especially since I've gone down a price
a lot but for the cons of wyverns really
there isn't that much I would say that
the only thing is is that they're more
there's more people killing wyvern so
you're probably going to have to fight
for a world most likely every time you
go but it only takes about 30 seconds
every trip to go ahead and find yourself
your own world or just crash someone out
of a spot with gargoyles I would say
that the pros of gargoyles is that it is
more consistent and relatively quiet at
least whenever I hopped world I was able
to find one person in a world in almost
half of the worlds and there's so many
spawns in the Slayer tower that you and
someone else can definitely share a
world pretty easily um the cons I guess
and the only real kind of gargoyles is
that it's pretty clique intensive um the
one thing I would recommend doing is
bringing a ring of wealth I think I said
that right I don't know if I messed that
up but yeah bring a ring of wealth it'll
collect all of your coins for you and I
mean other than that you can go like
down the stairs and Slayer tower come
back up and reget or we get re a growed
however the problem that I see with that
is and I tried doing that myself is that
the spawns are really like staggered and
you almost have to be within like a 1
square radius of the guard
for them to want to agro you so it's
very hard to do however you can't do
that your GP per hour goes significantly
down but yeah so I think we found all
that we needed to find gargoyles seem to
be a bit better you could blame it on
the fact that I didn't get that much
from wyverns as far as like bigger drops
but I guess that's just how it goes
sometimes you get unlucky and I mean
that could happen to you if you decided
to do one of these for an hour so hope
that video was helpful for you guys hope
you guys learned a little bit of
something out of it if you guys want to
play your mains on it if you guys want
to figure out what to do on a main or
what you want to do on at all hopefully
I was able to help you out but uh yeah
that'll be it for this video if you guys
liked the video feel free hit the like
if there's anything I can improve upon
let me know down below in the comments
and yeah if you guys want to see more
hit that subscribe button follow Twitter
follow the twitch Oliver all the above
before and stay in touch